today dispatch gets an emergency call
two hunters stranded on a remote River
deep in bear country have hit their 911
response button on an emergency
satellite tracking device a last line of
defense for those lost in the wilderness
sergeant Barlow and trooper Peterson
spring into action
dispatch limit
the state of Alaska has the highest rate
of missing person reports in the country
and many of them occur here in the
unforgiving wilderness of southern
Alaska
Hunter's could be hypothermic even worse
they're stranded in an area with one of
the highest concentrations of bear
mollies in Alaska it's critical the
troopers find them fast
go ahead
and being with my cells in hypothermia
is the both operational at all though is
okay
the hunters had set out on a bear
expedition but when a current tipped
their boat they lost their guns and
their way out of the Alaska wilderness
were you guys in the boat he wasn't
underneath the boat yeah it was totally
upside down
lift it off right
how long was into the water
the troopers evacuate the hunters to the
nearby town of Girdwood
the trip takes only minutes by chopper
but could have been disastrous if they
had attempted it on foot
at the airport a worried family is
waiting
daddy
today thanks to a tracking system and a
successful search and rescue this father
of three is lucky to be alive it could
have been a lot worse been a lot worse
you don't realize what you have until
you almost you know losing at the time
that had happened you don't know if
you'll ever see him again it just you
know worked out for the best